invité de 5 à 10 ce matin le sociologue
écrivain et rédacteur en chef des
cahiers du patrimoine qui signent leur
grand retour avec un premier volet
consacré aux sources de la musique
martiniquaise andré lucrèce
bonjourbonjour josé bicoeur on a envie
de dire que c'est une renaissance des
cahiers après un temps d'absence plutôt
long oui vous avez raison les cahiers se
sont invités pendant six ans et je pense
que enfin que je constate en tout cas
que chaque parution des cahiers et est
un événement et d'ailleurs c'est plus de
150 personnes à l'agora frantz fanon de
la ctm pour ce numéro
c'était si quelque chose absolument
extraordinaire ce soir là une vente
massive
enfin les gens attendaient avec
impatience des cahiers du patrimoine
alors aux sources de la musique
martiniquaise retrace les pratiques
musicales des amérindiens à nos jours
c'est ça tout à fait ce qui est
important de dire c'est que ça montre
que dans cet ouvrage on montre que la
musique est présente partout de la
naissance à la mort est aussi dans les
rites initiatiques entre autres tout à
fait alors je vous avais dit jusqu'à nos
jours
en effet sauf que nous nous sommes
arrêtés en 1950 tout à fait parce que le
deuxième volet voilà il y aura un
deuxième numéro qui sera consacré à la
musique martiniquaise et la modernité et
là nous avons voulu véritablement aller
aux sources où vous l'avez dit les
caraïbes avait une musique
il avait des instruments de musique qui
nous ont laissés d'ailleurs en partie je
pense aux halles usages qui a été fait
de la calebasse par exemple de vâlcea et
tous les marocains de maracas et donc et
puis nous nous sommes remontés et en
particulier nous avons constaté à quel
point finalement malgré un système aussi
inique est aussi cruelle que l'
esclavage et bien
nous les esclaves finalement se sont
battus pour construire précisément un
univers musical musique là tout à fond
on va rire venez on va essayer de
progresser et dans partant des
amérindiens les instruments servent
aussi à l'époque pas à communiquer tout
à fait tout à fait guéri en particulier
utilisé comme ça se passe d'ailleurs
dans pas mal de zones dans le monde dont
fait là où il ya des ddd conques de
lambi j'utilisais les comptes de
l'ambient et si je me suis aperçu
finalement que c'est une usagère
vraiment quasiment mondiale je ne sais
pas pas réservé qu'à la martinique si ça
voilà est-ce que la musique est est ce
que musique et danse à l'époque fond de
p1
oui oui alors mais chez les amérindiens
oui chez les caraïbes ont dansé au son
de la musique qui essentiellement chanté
et accompagné comme je le disais tout à
l'heure donc du chacha des maracas etc
et puis par ailleurs une musique qui
survient donc avec justement l'entrée et
si je puis dire sur le scène de la
société 28 caisses des esclaves
c'est le baylet il est laid est
absolument indissociable de la danse
alors maracas pour les pour les caraïbes
pour les amérindiens pardon mais le
tambour également bien le tambour arrive
avec les esclaves des tambours arrive
avec les esclaves et d'ailleurs il ya
une description précise de dents dans le
cahier de la manière dont on fabrique le
tango à partir d'un tronc d'armes très
bien donc qu'à l'époque des esclaves
la musique aussi devient pour l'esclave
qui a travaillé toute la journée un
exutoire
tout à fait alors mon ami
si rené le peste dit que le pratiquement
le seul plaisir les esclaves étaient les
rapports sexuels mais y'en a un autre
c'est la musique la musique parce que
c'est pour eux finalement un moyen de
créer quelque chose et en même temps de
se recréer dans une société comme je le
disais tout à l'heure aussi cruel et on
a constaté par exemple qu'ils font des
kilomètres et des kilomètres pour
rejoindre du semant des rassemblements
musicaux et ils le font après leur
travail et ils auront ils le font ils
chantent la nuit et il est donc vous
voyez d'ailleurs rien connecteur qui le
dit au lieu de se reposer pour être en
forme au travail le matin non pas sur
nuit par exemple à chanter et à danser
tout à fait et ce qui est aussi
importante dans justement parlant ce
chroniqueur c'est la façon dont on dans
ce site
on a l'impression qu'il faut avoir cette
force de la terre la puisaye toujours en
tapant des talents faisant remonter
l'énergie vers versoix oui tout à fait
c'est cela en fait si vous voulez si les
esclaves non pas ça c'est ce que
sociologue américain mais d'origine
jamaïcaine appelé la mort sociale et les
esclaves ne veulent pas mourir
socialement ils veulent avoir une
activité qui est une socialite et parce
que sais-je insiste là-dessus
les rassemblements musicaux c'est le
début d'une socialité web et donc
l'esclave y tient et et son énergie
passe là-dedans effectivement pour
s'exprimer alors en terme d'instruments
on disait qu'on avait
le tombeau le petit bois est aussi le
cas quoi l'ancêtre du des maracas c'est
ça tout à fait et puis en même temps
aussi le père là bas le note dès la fin
du xviie siècle une sorte de violon qui
est fait à pattes qui construit à partir
justement des calebasses tout à fait et
à quel moment ce fait la jonction
puisque vous parlez de violon entre la
musique pratiqué par les par les
esclaves et celle des colons
à quel moment ça se fait à partir du
moment où émerge la ville et en
particulier saint-pierre et c'est pour
ça précisément que la biguine l'origine
de la biguine c'est saint pierre
pourquoi parce que tout simplement il ya
des gens qui ceux qui ont une activité
économique et qui peuvent par exemple se
payer des instruments aux la biguine ne
peut pas se satisfaire uniquement de
duty bois et du tambour et donc il faut
qu'il y ait un apport instrumentale et
vous noterez d'ailleurs que les premiers
apports justement instrumentaux font une
place tout à fait particulière la câline
est studio et clarinettiste les hard et
karine et east & jehn de l'ouche et
karine et east et jeunes j'en passe et
des meilleures oeuvres après bien
d'autres encore et donc donc c'est à ce
moment-là à partir du moment où on sort
de la ruralité
je veux dire que la ville s'ajoutent à
la ruralité que là on crée donc une
musique nouvelle sous la forme de la
bima chaque région sa musique ou parce
qu'on a l'impression que on parle de la
biguine à saint-pierre rythme et au
françois par exemple c'est pas la
biguine si on en parle plus de haut
taille non non alors ce qu'il faut bien
voir c'est d'abord que la biguine va
évidemment être gêné par tour de
rayonner dans toute la société nicaise
mais il y avait effectivement des
régionalismes par exemple déjà sous le
bénin on parle de belles et 10,6 et des
belles et niort et donc effectivement
vous avez raison là il ya une société
une socialite et paysannes qui émergent
dans la région du fonds soirée du
saint-esprit et c'est à ce moment là que
effectivement on travaille sous la base
de la kadri et qui va devenir donc
ensuite et évoluer vers la route à la
hauteur ce qui ressort ou 6 6 2 de
l'ouvreur sig l'importance de
de la richesse de la création six as et
il fallait créer poursuit pour vivre
même pas pour survivre pour vivre êtres
vivants oui alors précisément je crois
que le rôle des cahiers du patrimoine
sur toute une série de thématiques mais
particulièrement sur celle ci si de
montrer au moment où il ya une sorte de
pessimisme ambiant en martinique que
nous avons créé des choses nous avons
créé en particulier une culture
extrêmement riche
nous allons payer une langue ne faut pas
l'oublier le créole et nous avons créé
une musique et une musique qui a rayonné
en 1920 lorsque on sort de la guerre de
14-18 et paris est amorphe paris est
plutôt touché par si vous voulez tout ce
qui touche à la mort et donc c'est une
atmosphère un peu morbide apparaît
précisément les musiciens martiniquais
je les cite est tout à l'heure c'était
lié aux aléas des deux louches les
guadeloupéens vont venez aussi les
rejoindre ali au va et c'était un petit
peu plus tard et donc ce sont eux qui
font danser paris et est donc est hélas
ils sont salués précisément par le
musicien américain cole porter qui écrit
un texte qui s'appelle begins the
biggest tout à fait mais il ya aussi max
roach qui en ici en martinique lors d'un
concert et de master class avec grand
batteur max roach gros match au gymnase
qui dit clairement martyn keith je n'ai
rien à vous apprendre pense que même la
biguine je ne suis pas la jouer tout à
l'heure il ne la comprenait pas cette
musique
oui tout à fait parce que ça n'est pas
le jazz qui la musique émergente
doucement des américains c'est une
musique très particulière et
effectivement il y a un talent derrière
cela très bien alors deuxième volume il
nous reste un peu de temps le deuxième
volume qui sera consacré à la musique
demain partir de
1960 tout à fait parce qu'en 1971 dans
la modernité
les instruments sont nouveaux les choses
évoluent la manière même de jouer les
orchestres va évoluer aussi par exemple
évoqué ce jusqu'à la jouer assis pour se
mettre debout maintenant pour jouer dont
vous avez toute une évolution et nous
voulons là aussi marqué cette évolution
et montrer la richesse considérable de
ce pays un pays que l'on dit pays du
piano n'oubliez pas
andré des creux de lucrèce je vous
remercie je l'appelle que vous êtes le
rédacteur en chef des cahiers du
patrimoine et que ce retour est marqué
vous vous éditez donc aux sources de la
marty de la musique martiniquaise
merci encore merci à vous